il y a quatre équipes denis coderre
annoncé en campagne électorale qu'elle
voulait augmenter le nombre de voies
réservées à montréal 210km 370 on a
décidé de prioriser l'implantation de
voies réservées voire plus de voies
réservées
est-ce que la promesse a été tenue on
est bien
denis coderre aura atteint en 4 ans 46%
de son objectif
en 2013 il y avait 110 km de voies
réservées à la fin de son mandat il y en
aura 200 28,9
c'est un peu plus du double juste pour
vous donner une idée montréal on vient
de le dire 228,9 km de voies réservées
vancouver 156,2 toronto 24 km cependant
sachez qu'il ya une différence entre ce
que denis coderre candidat à la mairie
en 2013 a dit est ce que la société de
transport de montréal a dit après son
élection la stm ne répond françois ça
fait quatre ans qu'on dit que pour le
375e anniversaire de montréal
on veut qu'il y ait 375 km de mesures
préférentielles pour les autobus alors
pas seulement les voies réservées
ça inclut aussi les flux chandelles qui
donne la priorité aux autobus sur les
feux rouges
c'est vrai que la stm dit ça depuis
quatre ans par contre ce n'est pas ce
que denis coderre avait promis en
campagne électorale il avait 10 370 km
de voies réservées et la preuve on l'a
dans le programme de son parti politique
si vous voulez qu'on vérifie quelque
chose écrit minutes
[Musique]